aujourd'hui plus de 9000 saint
quentinois ou 75 ans et plus alors si le
territoire reste moins marquée par le
vieillissement de sa population que le
reste de la france
les études réalisées par l'institut de
promotion de la santé de saint quentin
en yvelines note une hausse de l' indice
de vieillissement l'agglomération
propose bien sûr des services la plupart
est rassemblé dans un site
lemay renter à magny les hameaux d
accueil de jour pour personnes en
situation de handicap vieillissantes ou
atteintes d'une pathologie cognitif de
telles qu'alzheimer on va avoir
également sur place le service de soins
infirmiers à domicile qui va réaliser au
domicile des personnes en perte
d'autonomie des soins de confort et
d'hygiène
on va également y trouver une équipe
spécialisée alzheimer qui vint au
domicile depuis 2015 il existe aussi une
plateforme aux d'avis elle permet
d'accompagner les personnes âgées et les
aidants familiaux à trouver les bons
services d aide à domicile elle propose
aussi des ateliers actuellement en visio
autour de différentes thématiques
on peut aussi noter sur le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines la présence de
l'entreprise blue inea ans basé à
elancourt
la société propose notamment une
plateforme de téléassistance et un
bouton d'appel 24 heures sur 24 afin de
lutter contre l'isolément des personnes
âgées
on a dans nos partenaires par exemple
les autonomies planner est une équipe
qui se déplace sur directement auprès du
domicile de ces personnes âgées et qui
va coordonner ce qui se passe donc entre
une plateforme à distance des objets qui
nous permet d'être connecté et après une
équipe qui va être sur place on a tout
un continuum en 2019 plus de 90% des
seniors de 75 ans et plus vivent est
encore à leur domicile en france